we know Chadwick isn't here with us
tonight in the physical body but we feel
him all over this premiere for sure what
can you say to fans about how not only
Chadwick but t'challa is honored
throughout the film I can say that you
know we were
extremely
um
just proud of how Ryan has brought a
script that could honor Chad that can
honor t'challa I'm so proud of the way
us as a family the wakandan family that
you know and love has come together to
bring you a second installment only the
most broken
[Music]
foreign
but as he's looking down at us we're
hoping that this film just makes him
proud and we're hoping that you guys are
proud of us for what we've brought to
you so November 11th I'm just excited
for you guys to see it
show them
who we are you know I'm a big fan of
shuri I'm a big fan of yours and you're
getting like a counterpart in this film
Riri another badass black girl who's
smart as hell I love how we're
celebrating and empowering women in this
way
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah black women are being empowered and
black women are being celebrated for all
their beauty for their intelligence and
all that they are so November 11th big
things
foreign